how are you doing we're both lucky it's
a good day congratulations on the first
yes yes Jennifer thank you yeah one
thing to solve the murder mystery but I
love the storyline of the splits the
Spitz
the suspicious how would you describe
their relationship and love it true love
and the journey they go through and find
out aha moment about themselves yeah
that's a good question go ahead well no
I don't want to I like when you take 15
years into the relationship we've been
together a long time do something a
little special
my little unaware of this run where
listen such a it's such a fall we were
having fun very normal dynamic between
men and women yes and then we surprised
as me and we go in a whirlwind
vacation and we end up on a yacht Luke
Evans monkey wrench into the whole thing
we do yes we find each other again we
you know I bring the spark back this
like I said we've fell back in love but
I was always in love with you you just
you just worked well maybe I wasn't but
didn't know what I said I told you I was
like well we cut that part of the movie
out yeah yeah sure where I give them the
ultimatum like that's right someone's
like every marriage at there right just
finding yourself back to marriage within
a marriage within a marriage exactly
right if you were to have a
murder-mystery dinner let's say if you
had to invite two celebrity friends who
would you invite this is a common
question is it oh yes I mean not that's
about a question uh let's see any
celebrity anyone anyone you drive around
with Jennifer in real life always tells
me I'd love to have a dinner with
Courtney Cox and watch her get murdered
sometimes it's just one turn I was just
came up with a name that I thought the
world would associate you having a
dinner with there okay so there may be
question led me to a bad place
URI must be somebody wait oh okay so at
dinner where a murder takes place do
they have to be famous no because I
can't stand this one guy who lives down
the street from me okay yes Lance Lance
okay let's do Lance Lance comes over
Aniston and I are eating with him
somebody segment on that little story
that I just told the question should
have been asked yeah it shouldn't be no
I blame Canada you blame Canada and you
know what he since you've been on Ellen
arrow it's asking that question about
friends over and over you it doesn't
matter what you say yes nor maybe so it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter I just
want to say happy 25th anniversary
that's a bo yes time it was so important
to us I've always been curious about her
story now what was the most important
meaningful story that she did that was
important to you I would probably say
having a kid right on her own that was I
think a real real moment for her yeah
that was and then going and then having
the you know the the the could the sort
of through line that of Rachel and Ross
I think that was fairly fun and special
to watch
you